hello everyone and welcome to what I
imagine will be a fairly lengthy video
but for a good reason today is a rest
day in the Tata steel chess tournament
and uh I'm going to show not one not two
but three games from round four first
one will be Anish giri versus GES the
one you see here then we're going to sh
Yani pish versus Alexander donchenko and
then lastly Wei versus param makulu I
sort of organized them for you uh you
know uh sort of by ascending uh Madness
uh
uh by by the moves that were made on the
board um so we're going to go from
positional to really you can't even
imagine what's going to be played next
and uh yeah you will have um uh sort of
chapters uh underneath the video if you
guys want you can also pick you don't
have to watch the entire video but as
usual I suggest you do you also will
have the standings the uh the rankings
and you know the pairings for uh for
this round for the next round and so on
so do check it out uh you know
everything is in the description below
now that being said let's check out the
first game Anish giri versus GES Anish
giri the defending Champion opens with
Pawn to C4 he goes for the English
opening we have E5 Knight to C3 Knight
to F6 Knight to F3 and Knight to C6
pretty much the Four Knights of the
English is what you will see every time
when Grand Masters play unless there's
maybe a dub of playing he might throw in
something else uh D3 with Pawn to D5
captures captures and now Pawn to G3 the
uh the fing kto line the B is now coming
to G2 uh unusual Castle King side we
have Knight back to F6 and this is
already a a very rare
move uh usually either Bishop to E7 is
played or the Knight is retreated to B6
uh very few games where the Knight
Returns uh to to F6 where it came from
but okay Bishop to G5 we have Bishop to
E7 and now Bishop to G2 both players
Castle so castles castles uh H6 and
nishe decides to give up the dark Square
Bishop so captures captures and now uh
there is a game where Knight to D2 was
played but we have Rook to B1 here by
Anish and it is now as of move 11 that
we have a completely new game Anish of
course knows how to play a really strong
chest and he wants to throw in B4 as
soon as possible and it would be a bit
risky with the Rook on A1 then you might
run into trouble if for example E4 is
played so here Rook B1 and gkes of
course understands this he plays Pawn to
A5 stops Pawn to B4 we have A3 again
preparing Pawn to B4 and now Knight to
D4 uh putting pressure on the Knight on
F3 but also uh maybe with some ideas of
of getting the Knight to B3 at some
point if possible if you can get some
like Bishop to E6 or even Bishop to B3
uh will be uh crippling so here we have
E3 chasing away the Knight right away
captures we have captures uh but not
with the queen uh Anish captured with
the bishop and now Pawn to C6 this makes
the bishop not as stronger piece we have
Queen to C2 and now Bishop to F5 putting
pressure on that D3 Pawn so F to D1 and
now Queen to
D7 and here by Queen to D7 gkes is
preparing to uh connect well he
connected the Rooks he wants to get the
Rooks into the game but he also has
given up control over some dark squares
here and Anish uses this opportunity to
get his Knight to a more um uh prominent
Square now B6 or C5 would be excellent
and it also will come with a Tempo on
the queen so Queen to C7 gues forced to
waste another Tempo B4 now uh a c cap a
captures now Rook F to d8 continuing the
pressure on the D3 pawn and now just
Pawn to B5 by Anish beautifully played
as the queen on C7 is undefended and now
uh well let's see how you could play
this you could play Bishop D7 if you
want to play uh if you want to play it
safe but even with this you will have to
give up your Pawn here for example Queen
captures on C6 and after Queen captures
and Bishop captures the Knight on A4 is
defended and uh you're just going to be
down a pawn so gukesh had a different
idea he played Rook captures on
D3 uh it looks scary uh because uh well
the D3 square is defended twice but the
queen is also sort of overloaded uh
guarding the Knight on A4 that's the
idea here so Rook captures on D3 Bishop
captures we have Queen captures and now
Rook captures on A4 B captures on C6 B
captures and now even Bishop captures on
C6 an says no you will not be up a pawn
because now if you take my Bishop um of
course a rook to B8 and you're getting
checkmated the queen covers the H7
Square so Rook to A7 as The Rook is also
attacked on A4 Rook to A7 and now we
have Bishop back to D5 uh Queen to d8
putting pressure on the bishop maybe uh
thinking about some Rook to D7 moves uh
Now Pawn to H4 still Rook to D7 doesn't
really do all that much if you go Rook
to D7 Rook just goes to B5 and since
these are light squares the dark Square
Bishop doesn't really have a say in this
so after H4 we have Pawn to H5 uh and
now Rook to B5 by
Anish uh and now uh safest here would be
Rook to A5 you just trade off the Rooks
and you play this opposite color Bishop
end game uh but even by safest I don't
mean this that that it's like a dead
draw or anything for example captures
captures uh and it's still uh you have
the problem of the F7 Pawn look at how
Anish has a Pawn on E3 so it's very hard
for this bishop to actually attack the
F2 Pawn in order for the bishop to
attack the F2 Pawn you would have to put
it to E1 and then maybe have the queen
on the second rank to put any pressure
on F2 but because gush's spawn is not an
E6 it's an E5 it's very easy for anishia
Bishop to attack the F7 pawn and that's
the thing with the Bishops of opposite
colors yes they are a draw uh if you
have like
um like a fairly equal end game but with
Queens on the board it's always as if
one side is a pie up because if you're
attacking with the queen and the bishop
on light squares the dark Square Bishop
is you know just an observer it's um
non-existent so instead after after Rook
B5 we have Rook to D7 uh and now uh this
beautiful beautiful move by Anish Queen
to B3 just gets the queen out of Harm's
Way puts pressure on F7 and also
prepares the real threat of Rook to B8
winning the queen and it seems like um
it's possible to get out of this fairly
easily uh Queen to E7 was played but now
uh what's the real uh what's the real
threat here what's uh the one way that
Anish can use to end the game on the
spot pretty much feel free to pause the
video and try to win the game as quickly
as possible while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting the move even on nich didn't go
for and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Queen to B1 take
away the H7 Square from the black king
and also stop G6 G6 cannot be played due
to Queen captures on G6 the F7 Pawn is
played and now it doesn't matter what
you play you can control the back rank
but then Queen to F5 comes and now
there's the problem of the H5 pawn and
the real trick is after Queen to D7
attacking the queen and the Rook sort of
forcing a queen trade you just say you
can have the Rook Queen captures an H7
and that's it as the F7 Pawn will fall
and here white is just in a completely
winning position and of course if you
capture The Rook then it's just a nice
mate in two regardless of where the
black king goes uh Queen to H5 will be
Checkmate uh so Queen to B1 definitely
the strong here however Anish went for
Bishop to C6 first and this sort of
allows Gish back into the game Rook to
D6 uh Rook to B8 with check we have Rook
to d8 and now Rook to B7 winning the
seventh rank of course the F7 Pawn has
to be defended so Queen to E6 offering a
queen trade and here un each trades we
have captures captures and now Bishop
back to E4 So This Is the End Game Anish
is not up in material but he does have
the well gkes has the double ewn which
uh is a pretty big weakness so here we
have Pawn to G5 by gkes uh Bishop to H7
with check very nicely done by Anish
King to h8 and now H captures on G5
Bishop captures and Bishop to G6
attacking the H5 Pawn showing that you
cannot defend it because if H5 you can
just capture and if Bishop captures Rook
to H7 check will pick up the bishop so
there's no way to avoid this Rook to D1
check was played uh King to G2 now Rook
to D2 hoping for Bishop captures on E3
three uh but Anish of course will not
allow that King F1 now H4 and just G
captures on H4 there's no way to avoid
this bishop to F6 uh and now Rook to F7
attacking the bishop Bishop to G7 and
pawn to H5 we have Rook to d8 uh Pawn H6
although it looks completely winning uh
is not winning just yet because black
will just capture it and after Rook H7
check King G8 Rook captures you have
this King G7 attacking bishop and Rook
so you will you you wi win back material
and it's going to be a draw so never
rush things in chess Rook D E7 was
played uh now Bishop to F6 attacking The
Rook Rook captures on E6 and now Rook to
f8 defending the bishop and now Bishop
to F5 by an again sort of allowing GES
back into the game uh he he misses it by
by a Tempo he does play King to G2 on
the next move but it was crucial to play
it here uh point being that after King
G7 uh King G2 and King G7 the Bishop is
defended so you can March your king
forward and after King H6 you have King
G4 and now the king defends the pawn and
now it's okay to move the bishop for
example Bishop to G7 Bishop to F5 with a
nice Discovery here and after Bishop to
F6 you will play Bishop to E4 forcing
black to make a move the Rook can't
really move the bishop cannot move you
can move the king but now F3 and after
King H6 or something King to F5 and now
that's pretty much it uh the bishop is
lost or you defended with the King now
now H6 check uh and then the bishop is
lost so this is uh the cleanest way
however Anish played Bishop to F5 first
and now he allowed King to G7 King to G2
and King H6 but now he's not in time as
the pawn is hanging so he has to waste
another move Bishop to G4 was played
King to G5 already giving Gish a lot of
activity with his King we have King to
G3 uh Rook to F7 now we have Rook to B6
and now Rook to f8 Rook to B7 and now
King to H6 so now gkes says uh all right
your possession might still be winning
but um you will have to work hard for it
so okay uh Rook A7 by Anish we have
Bishop to G7 uh Bishop to F3 and now
Rook to F5 uh we have Rook to B7 there's
really not much for GES to do but but
wait uh Rook to f8 and Bishop to E4 we
have Rook back to F6 Rook to D7 and now
Rook to f8 we have Rook back to A7 uh
Rook to F6 and now Rook to A2 putting
pressure defending the F2 Pawn so the
king can now come forward uh Rook to f8
and King to G4 with the F2 Pawn nicely
defended Rook to F6 and now Bishop to F5
Now The Rook is cut off and you can
again activate your Rook so Rook to B6
and Rook back to A7 uh we have Rook to
C6 and now King to F3 again not finding
a clear way how to break through Rook to
C4 and now Bishop back to D3 Rook to C6
King to E4 uh Rook to F6 and now Pawn to
F3 defending the pawn bishop to h8 and
now uh Bishop to C4 uh we have Rook to
B6 and now comes Bishop to F7 Bishop to
G7 and now finally Bishop to G6 and here
black is already uh very much struggling
for moves Rook to F6 is still probably
the most precise way of uh just stopping
the king from advancing forward uh but
guash play Rook to B4 check and after
King to F5 he went for the PA pawns with
Rook to B3 but Anish just said you can
have the pawn Rook to A6 and now okay
the the pawn can be one but it doesn't
really do all that much if it captures
you will move the king back uh defend
the pawn now threaten very nasty
discoveries and once you play a move as
there really aren't all that many great
ones you will move the bishop with check
and once the king moves you will play H6
with check and after the king moves uh
just any move as now you will uh easily
win the game whatever black plays you
will play h 7 with check the bishop
nicely supports that and after King G7
Rook A7 check King to h8 and now Rook to
A8 and that's it the bishop is lost or
you defended the bishop uh and then just
Rook captures on f8 that's it if Rook if
Rook captures you will advance the pawn
to a queen and that's it so gkes cannot
capture the pawn he goes back Rook to B8
but it doesn't really change anything
Bishop F7 check King H7 King to G5 and
now Bishop to f8 we have Bishop to G6
with check King to h8 and now Rook to E
E6 and he was in this position un move
72 that GES resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here if you
play Bishop to G7 then a nice H6 is
coming uh and if you try something like
Rook to B5 to maybe go for some check it
doesn't really work again just Pawn to
H6 and if E4 check you can even go
forward you don't really care he
captures on F3 Rook E8 you go after the
bishop and wants some checks are given
let's say Rook B6 check King to F5 Rook
B5 check King F4 Rook B4 check King
captur now King G8 defends the bishop
again it's the exact same maneuver H7
check King G7 and Rook captures on f8
with h8 Queen next
Unstoppable so Anish wins round four
against gesh another tough loss for GES
Anish completely outplayed in
positionally and Anish is now on three
and a half out of four absolutely
incredible for the for the defending uh
Tata Steel champion uh but you know it's
still early in the tournament 13 Rounds
will be played only four have been
concluded
but now onto the other game and that is
yanomi versus Alexander donchenko so
let's see what happened in this one uh
much much more intense than the previous
one uh let's check it out so Yan with
the white pieces opens with Pawn to E4
we have Pawn to C5 Alexander goes for
the Sicilian Defense Knight F3 D6 and
now D4 we have captures captures and now
Knight to F6 Knight to C3 and just A6
okay the Knight of Sicilian is on the
board we've seen this many many times
and uh nepo decides that he does not
want to play any of the regular stuff he
just plays Bishop to D3 and if you are
interested this is the 10th most popular
continuation against the nidr Sicilian
uh so nepo wants to make sure that um
Alexander is definitely out of book of
course he's not completely out of book
he might know a few continuations but
maybe not you know have them thoroughly
analyzed and prepared um yeah for the
game against nepo so okay G6 preparing
to F to the dark Square Bishop f three
Bishop to G7 and Bishop to E3 pretty
standard moves here uh we have Knight B
to D7 and now Queen to D2 much like you
would play against um a regular Dragon
cilian we have Pawn to B5 uh and pawn to
A4 attacking the pawn chain Pawn to B4
and Knight to A2 we have Pawn to D5 now
uh often we say that if you can play D5
without you know you're ruining your
position in the Sicilian that you are at
least equal uh you're probably better
but you're at least equal so let's see
what happens here there is a game in the
database David Navara played against
Nikita Vito in the European team
championship of 2023 where Knight
captures on B4 was played but here we
have e captures on D5 by nippo and it is
now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game so okay Knight
captures on D5 we have Knight captures
on B4 uh and now Knight captures on E3
eliminating nipp was Bishop uh we have
Queen captures on E3 and now Queen to C7
so so what does nepo do he castles Queen
side uh could be a little bit dangerous
look at this bishop The Rook coming to
B8 but nepo is not worried he just um
donen goes Bishop to B7 and now Bishop
to E4 offering a trade we have castles
and nepo Trad on B7 captures captures
and now uh well uh if you're anyone
except nepo you are probably worried
about stuff like this but not nepo he
just goes Knight D to C6 uh defends his
Knight also puts pressure on the E7
Pawn uh and uh Alexander plays the
correct idea Pawn to A5 now you can't
really move the Knight not just because
of this you could let's play Knight D3
and defend the B2 Pawn but then the
Knight on C6 hang so you have to play
Knight captures on E7 with check or you
have to play Queen captures on E7 and
take the Knight here so that's exactly
what happens Queen captures on E7 a
captures on B4 nepo even welcomes this
move as it closes off the B file Queen
captures on D7 and now Queen to B6
avoiding the queen trade we have Knight
to E7 with check King h8 and now Knight
to D5 attacks the queen and the pawn
here Queen back to B uh to F2 and now
just um Pawn to
B3 uh making the the position more solid
and uh okay the the bishop here is an
absolute monster and if the queen could
somehow G gain access to this diagonal
it's probably game over but nepo made
sure that the queen cannot grab hold of
this diagonal so we have Rook a to d8
attacking the queen queen to B5 and now
just Queen captures on G2 yes okay it's
a it's a you know a dynamical position
dynamical dynamic position it's an
attacking game we have castles on
opposite sides of the board uh but still
if you can grab a pawn uh you should do
so because nepo is up in material so
Queen to F1 nepo offers a queen trade he
is up a pawn and just Queen to G5 with
check what is this did nepo just blunder
a blunder a knight on D5 uh not really
there's Pawn to F4 and of course now if
Queen captures The Rook defend so Queen
to H5 now comes Queen to C4 just nicely
defending the Knight we have Rook to C8
attacking the queen and here uh safest
would be to just move the queen to D3
for a very very obvious reason uh but
not as obvious as you might think so
here Queen captures on B4 was played
Naple just grabs another Pawn he says I
don't care about your attacking
potential I'm just going to advance the
pawns here and win the game once I trade
down material but there is a game uh
there is a move that he missed it's not
that it's a winning move or anything it
just makes wh's position a bit
uncomfortable uh and after thinking for
for about it for some time dun chenko
plays it Rook captures on C2 it's uh uh
so beautiful we're even going to do it
in slow motion look at this Rook
captures on C2 King captures only move
pretty much and Rook to C8 with check
and now the way you play this is not by
playing Knight to C E3 the move neppo
plade you actually have to go into the
center of the board with your king you
give up the Knight with check then King
E3 and your king is actually safe in the
middle of the board Queen to E6 check
for example Queen E4 and if Rook to C3
check you can even block with Rook to D3
for example captures captures Queen
captures and B3 with check King E2 but
still you're up the exchange of course
you're uh you're the one that uh is up
in material and if anything you should
be pushing for the win but black king is
very safe so you know all in all it's a
draw however Knight to C3 was played
here and now uh nepo misses a very very
uh tricky continuation so feel free to
pause the video and try to find a move
that uh donchenko played while I give
you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spending your uh rest day uh you know
doing great things and for those of you
who just want to enjoy to show it is
Queen to F3 not just grabbing the Knight
of course if you grab the Knight yes you
do win the queen but uh White has two
Rooks against the queen and also the two
connected pass pawns on the queen side
if anything you prefer white here so
instead uh Queen to F3 was played and
this is deadly now it's a a triple
attack on the Knight on C3 and also you
cannot bring another Defender you can
but if you bring another Defender then
The Rook on H1 hangs that's the that's
the key idea here but it is the only
move so Rook to D3 was played and not
not even Rook Queen captures Rook but
first queen to G2 with check being H
completely merciless here he wants to
grab the Rook with check so King to B1
now Queen captures on H1 with check
Knight to D1 and now Queen captures on
H2 and now look at the material
completely equal uh but nepo has a wide
open King on B1 and the blacking on h8
is is fairly safe so uh this is an
objectively winning position but the
question is can you win it against nepo
as a we know there are very few people
who just thrive in chaos the way nepo
does so uh Queen to D2 with play nip of
course wants to offer a queen trade and
queen to H4 of course you want to
decline this and you want to get your
queen to F6 to enjoy this um battery and
well hopefully Checkmate the white king
So King to A2 now nepo King should go up
the board it's much much safer than
being stuck in the corner Pon to H5 this
is a sort of introducing the principle
of the second weakness yes you will have
checkmating potential but you also want
this Pawn for example on H2 so you also
have the option of trading Queens um and
maybe winning the game this way so okay
Pawn to A5 we have King to H7 and now
Pawn to F5 you might think of something
like Pawn to B4 makes more sense but
nepo also wants to weaken the black king
it's very very safe with those three
pawns just guarding him so Queen F6
going for Queen to A1 check and now F
captures on G6 F captures and now Knight
to B2 preventing the queen from checking
the white king uh Rook to C five putting
pressure on the A5 Pawn uh and now Pawn
to B4 nicely defending we have Rook to F
uh Rook to F5 going after Rook to F2 if
this lands then it's just game over so
you have to do something Knight to D1
stops Rook to C2 but now you allow Queen
to A1 check but interestingly Queen to
A1 check is not a very strong if Queen
A1 check King to B3 how do you continue
Queen to B1 with Che check King to A4
Queen to A1 with check uh you can block
Rook A3 and if Queen to E5 you can even
play Queen to D7 grab hold of this
diagonal and that's pretty much it uh
now the the pawn just marches forward uh
black is still better but you know
nothing uh spectacular so instead Pawn
to H4 was played uh which is which is a
great move but I just want to show you
uh how a computer would would play this
attack and a computer would play this by
playing Queen to F7 with check uh and
after King A3 Bishop to H6 yeah it's
very uh very uh different than a human
things because your Bishop on G7 is so
spectacular you don't think about moves
like Bishop to H6 and now after the
queen moves you play Bishop to f8 with
the threat of Rook captures on A5 as the
B Pawn is pinned uh Queen to A4 stopping
that and now Rook to F4 and now Black's
attack is Unstoppable Rook to B3 good
defending uh on B4 now Queen C7 trying
to go
uh from behind and if Knight B2 then
Rook F1 threatening mate in one and
after you move the king now comes Queen
to C1 again threatening mate in one and
once you move the Rook so the King has a
sort of an escape Square now the bishop
returns to its rightful diagonal and now
it's game over the the Knight hangs with
Checkmate If you defend it Queen to A3
then Queen B1 check King to B3 and Rook
F2 and there is no more stopping Rook
captures on B2 and that's pretty much it
so it is possible to win this by four
course but even if you play the absolute
top computer moves it will still take
you like 10 11 precise moves uh which is
um some of you often say why why are you
showing us such crazy engine lines well
it's to always remind you guys that even
if your opponent is attacking you and
your position looks hopeless uh know
that he needs to make 10 incredibly
precise Moves In order to actually win
the position if he makes like 10
suboptimal moves then you will have a
chance to bounce back if you always play
the absolute best move so you know
always strive for for that so H4 was
played King to A3 and now Rook to F4
again Bishop to f8 was um the way to go
here introducing the threat of Rook
captur on A5 but Rook to F4 was played
and now Knight to C3 and now with nippo
Knight back into the game uh it's very
hard to actually push for something with
black here Rook to F2 was played
attacking the queen uh Queen D1 we have
Rook to F1 uh just Queen to D2 and now
uh okay you could give a check but again
it does nothing Queen to E6 was played
uh and now Queen to A2 stopping checks
by the rook and also offering a queen
trade Queen to E1 and now just Queen to
C4 and uh remarkable as it is there is
no more way for black to push this for a
win Queen to C1 check was played King to
B3 we have Rook to F4 attacking the
queen also stopping Queen captures on H4
now comes Queen to C7 and now after Rook
to F2 nepo decided to go for Rook to D7
and now with the threat of captures on
G7 uh black is just not in time to do
any any damage here Queen to C2 check
was played King to A3 now Queen to C1
with check King to A4 and now Queen to
A1 with check nip goes to B5 but now
after Queen to F1 check he returns to A4
as uh well trying anything else would be
would be over pushing it I can't show
you what happens like if he goes to B6
uh the problem is is this Rook to F6
check and now you cannot go up the board
because uh just Queen to A6 so you're
going to have to go down the board and
now Queen to F5 check uh forces the the
white king back King C4 Queen to F4 with
check forces a queen trade and even if
you go for this it still uh doesn't
matter uh oh sorry not King
B3 uh you will go up the board of course
and now after H3 uh it looks uh very
very strong but and even the Knight here
is hanging but uh not for the moment as
the bishop is spin but you can move the
Knight with some uh crucial temp Rook F2
Knight to G3 now guarding the queening
square and after Rook F3 Knight to E4
going for this check and winning The
Rook but H2 you don't care about the
Rook as the queen is more important uh
Rook to D1 and after let's say Rook F4
attacking the Knight Knight G5 check
King to H6 Knight to E6 with a nice Fork
here Rook F5 check King to C6 and now
Rook to F6 attacking the Knight King D5
uh and now finally Pawn to G5 you are
hoping to get the other Pawn up the
board white will play A6 something like
Rook to H1 uh sorry something like Rook
to F2 Rook to H1 going for this capture
after black of course goes after the a
pawn Rook to A2 and now you'll just play
A7 and that's pretty much it you either
allow Rook captur on H2 check and the
promotion to a queen or you just capture
on A7 then Rook captures on H2 and now
with equal material it it's going to be
a fairly quick draw but they don't try
that they've had enough King to A4 we
have Queen to A1 with check King to B5
Queen to F1 with check King to A4 and
after Queen to A1 check it was in this
position on move 56 that nepo and
Alexander donchenko agreed to a draw as
there is nothing more to be done here so
brilliant game by donchenko he was never
really in any trouble uh nepo uh
defended well as nepo usually does it's
I mean it's absolutely incredible how he
escapes these um dead lost positions uh
but that's the thing I mean it's dead
lost if you play very very precise moves
which uh it's of course very very hard
to do for a human so uh you're probably
wondering if I said that uh I'm sure I'm
going to show you these three games you
know um sort of uh in the order of
ascending Madness what what's the third
game going to be like well yeah the
third game is going to be really really
wild so the third game that we are
showing is Wei versus uh param makulu uh
nothing to say about this game other
than let's check it out so uh we opens
with Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to C6 by
haaram going for the caroan we have D4
D5 and now Pawn to E5 going for the
advanced variation uh Bishop to F5 and
now Knight to F3 the so SoCal short
variation we have Pawn to E6 as the
bishop is now out of the cage so you can
close the structure Bishop to E2 and now
Knight to E7 we have castles and pawn to
C5 sort of losing a Tempo but this is
the way this is played uh we have Decap
cap on C5 and now Knight E to C6 with
have Bishop to G5 attacking the queen
queen E7 captures captures and now uh
there is a game where C4 was played but
here we have Knight to A3 and it is now
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game so okay param castles we have
Pawn to C4 uh Rook to d8 nicely aligning
with the White Queen and now Knight to
B5 going after that D6 Square you do
have very nice support for it and now
Queen captures on C5 by also you could
consider something like d captures and
C4 and after Knight comes to D6 Knight
A6 to attack the C5 Pawn but he decides
to go this way and now Knight to C7 as
usual param just gives up a rook that's
just how he how he plays chess D
captures in C5 and now Queen to C5 uh
Queen to C1 uh Sid stepping The Rook
Knight captures on E5 we have Knight
captures on A8 now grabbing the rook and
after Knight beat to C6 of course you
will recapture on A8 now now comes
Knight captures on E5 Knight captures
and queen to C3 just nicely developing
Rook captures on A8 and now Pawn to B3
trying to go after this C4 Pawn uh which
uh was not played but it could be played
uh way you of course chooses the more
fun way Bishop captures on C4 seemingly
sacrificing a piece but uh it's merely
uh temporarily so Pawn to B3 Pawn to B5
and now B captures on C4 we have Rook to
C8 uh you have to win your Pawn somehow
Rook eight to C1 and now B captures on
C4 we have Rook F to D1 and now just
King to f8 so if you look at the
possession now param has two pawns for
the sacrificed exchange but um uh it
still is a bishop against a rook uh but
the pawns are on light Square so if you
imagine this bishop coming to D5 he's
going to have a protected Pawn on C4
with an incredible attacking piece
eyeing that G2 Pawn so I mean it's very
hard not to prefer black here so okay
Rook to D4 going after the pawn here and
now look at parham's beautiful move
Bishop to D3 and you're like what what
is this how how is this possible can I
not just capture the bishop and then
take the the free material you could if
uh The Exchange happened anywhere other
than on D3 and if the the white king
wasn't on G1 but here for example if you
go for this then captures captures
captures captures yes you are upper Rook
but now D2 and you don't have Rook C1
and you don't have Rook D5 and the white
king is too far away so this is one
particular position where Bishop to D3
is possible in such a situation so Rook
to D7 was
played uh and now King to E8 just
bringing the king closer to the action
uh Rook to B7 and now Bishop to E4 we
have Rook to B4 putting pressure on the
pawn now Queen to G5 first threatening
Checkmate we have Pawn to G3 and now
Bishop to D5 so the position position
that we've discussed the bishop on D5
guarding C4 doesn't matter how many
Rooks you have unless you're ready to
give up your Rook you're not touching
the C4 Pawn so Rook C to B1 doubling up
on the B file maybe trying to get rid of
one of the Rooks of the board just Pawn
to F6 now the E Pawn might also Advance
forward but uh for the moment you you
really like your setup here and you like
the possibility of your king going to F7
if needed so Queen to C2 putting
pressure on the pawn here uh just Pawn
to A5 attacking The Rook we have Rook to
B5 going after the pawn uh now Queen to
H5 saying that okay you can capture the
pawn here but then um you will also have
to give up The Rook for the bishop
because once Queen H3 is played uh the
only way to avoid Checkmate will be to
give up U The Rook for Bop which is a
possibility of course but we goes for an
even stronger move Queen A4 now
threatens all sorts of nasty discoveries
here King F7 and The Rook captures on A5
and now the difference is uh and it's a
very tricky maneuver by we if you go
Queen to well even Queen F3 just trying
to Checkmate the white king this way uh
there's this tricky Queen D7 check and
after the king moves now you just pick
up the bishop but also the Rook here is
hanging sorry uh and uh at the end of
this line you would be up a full Rook so
that's the idea be behind Queen to A4 so
Rook to d8 was played stopping this
queen to D7 check if Queen to F3 is
played but now Rook to A7 with check
King to G6 and queen to C2 with check we
have King H6 Queen to D2 with check and
we have a repetition here uh but not for
long as we goes for Rook to A3 and Rook
to A3 is such a way move um uh that was
made with seven seconds on the clock so
here we is playing an increment
basically until uh two more moves he
needs to make move 40 to reach time
control and the A3 prepares a really
nasty idea and it's just brilliant how
we can create such a such position with
uh 7 seconds on the clock uh Queen to F7
was played of course going for Queen E4
but now Rook to E1 stopping that and now
Rook to B8 preparing to bring the Rook
into the game and look at Way's move 40
so you have to make one more move to
reach time control and okay you gain
additional time uh you could play
something you know calm but no way plays
G4 and I mean beautiful that that it's
possible to make such a move on move 40
of course the pawn cannot be touched if
you capture then Rook to G3 three this
was the idea behind Rook to A3 uh
winning the queen and also if Queen to
G5 just offering a queen trade then F4
and all of a sudden uh you're not going
to be able to to withstand the attack F5
check and after King to F7 you can
capture here uh and after let's say Rook
to G3 now guarding the the G Pawn let's
say Rook to B6 adding another Defender
here you play G5 and uh what black is
down material if uh if white also has
the attack and if the position opens up
if the the black king will not be safe
uh then he's going to be completely
winning uh but interestingly Parham
plays the absolute best move here and
that is Queen to B1 he sacrifices his
queen or rather tries to offer a queen
sacrifice because then Rook captures
will be checkmated the bishop covers the
G2 Square uh so move 40 has been played
time control has been reached and of
course Wei just continues with Pawn to
H4 he creates some more breathing room
for his King and now the queen is in
real trouble so Queen back to B6 very
very important defensive idea otherwise
Queen to C2 with check King has to go
back uh you know amidst all the pawns
here and then Rook to A7 check would be
deadly but Queen to B6 stops that so
Pawn to H5 with check King F7 and now
Queen to E3 offering a queen trade and
here param said all right you've you've
done your we stuff I'm just going to
trade Queens here and let's uh you know
agree to a draw here uh and probably if
he made one particular move it would be
so but but instead he played Bishop to
E4 here and now his position is uh lost
all of a sudden uh feel free to pause
the video and try to find the only
winning idea for we while I give you a
couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations and
realizing that uh one check will prevent
the black king from ever getting off of
the back ring and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
to A7 and no doubt a lot of you guys
have found this move and probably a more
difficult question would be to find the
only move that doesn't lose uh here in
this position before param made this
move and that move was Pawn to F5 now
that you've seen Rook to A7 you know
that the reason is that the king gains
access to the king side and if we try
some let's say moves like the G captures
G captures Rook to D1 going after the
bishop Bishop to E4 and even Rook to D7
check yes it looks scary because the
Rooks are promoted the pigs you have
King F6 and if Rook a A7 you have Rook
to B1 with check and now look at this
King H2 C3 and now after Rook to F7
check King G5 how are you stopping King
H4 and just Rook to H1 Checkmate that's
the problem here and not only that uh
even if you stop that you still have to
worry about C2 C1 which is just
completely winning so uh F5 was the way
to go here but after Bop to E4 we takes
control of the position by playing Rook
to A7 check the king now has to go back
and now just Rook to C1 and the real
weird thing about this is is that uh
when they were both low on the clock
where when we created that insane
position with the G4 Rook A3 uh param
matched uh his in you know uh Madness
sort of blow by blow but now uh once
time control has been reached you have
like over an hour on the clock now you
play a move and um he didn't didn't
really even think about this you just
play Bishop D4 with like I mean maybe
spending a minute on it uh but okay
Bishop to D3 of course stopping this and
now Rook to C3 preparing Rook A3 and
then doubling up on the seventh rank
with the black king stuck on the back
rank not in the game as in the line that
we've shown so okay we have Pawn to G5
uh now comes a rook C to A3 we have Rook
to C8 now just Rook to
G7 of course not touching the pawn you
I'm sure you guys have not forgotten
about our good friend the bishop on C on
D3 King to f8 and now Rook 8 to A7 we
have Pawn to C3 uh Rook eight to F7
check and now okay he harassed the black
king here a little bit before he decided
on a way on how to go about it and that
is the trade Rooks Rook e to C7 Rook
captures on C7 Rook captures Now Pawn to
C2 yes you have a defended pass Pawn on
C2 and uh it could be very nice but what
do you do about the past a pawn so just
Pawn to A4 we have Pawn to H6 uh Pawn to
A5 we have Pawn to F5 and now King to F2
uh King to E8 and just G captures on F5
we have e captures King to E1 now the
king can also help out with the the
advanced E Pawn uh G4 we have King to D2
now comes Bishop to E4 uh and pawn to A6
now G3 we have King to E1 also you have
to be ready with King to F2 if G2 lands
uh King to d8 attacking the rook and
just Rook to C3 so guarding everything
this Rook covers this queening Square
the king will cover this queening square
and that's pretty much it King to E7 was
played of course the king cannot Advance
over the C file to go after the a pawn
so King to E7 was played Pawn to A7 and
now King to F6 and here there are many
ways you can win this but just Rook
captures on C2 and he was in this
position on move 69 add that param
makulu resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so very
nice uh but but yeah uh of course you
you you take the Rook the pawn promotes
you don't take the Rook you can just
play something anything like Rook to C8
and then promote the pawn the bishop
will have to be sacrificed he will have
a full Rook uh so there is nothing more
you can uh do here uh so yeah I hope you
enjoyed all three games and as promised
here are the uh the standings and the
well first let's uh check out uh uh
let's check out the uh results from
round four so Wei defeated Max you've
seen the game ding L lost to Prana the
prag incredible win against the world
champion in classical with the black
pieces nepo against donchenko a draw but
if you haven't seen the game like you
have uh you think okay maybe it was like
a boring Berlin no it wasn't uh Anish
defeating gues you know just a nice
positional Masterpiece um ala and Notre
okay it was a bit of a fight but I think
it was you know more of an early draw
Jordan versus VD to draw and Max versus
women's world champion juun also a draw
and the standings after four rounds have
been played like I said the leader with
three and a half points Onish giri with
three points ala with two and a half
points prand nck and way and Yan pishi
with two points we have ver Ding and Max
vam point and a half gkas and yordan Van
Forest one point juun and Alexander
donchenko and and half a point uh
someone who almost qualified for the FED
candidates tournament it is param makulu
at 27 for sitting at a rating of 2740
it's just not his not his tournament
you've seen that every game that he lost
someone had like a moment of Brilliance
that lasted for an entire game like way
did here I mean how do how do you fight
that uh so yeah it's not that he's
playing poorly or anything if anything
he's playing incredible chess is just
that you know his opponents um don't
seem to care uh so yeah those were the
games hope you guys enjoyed that uh if
any of you watched all of them you know
congratul ulations you you you're know
an incredible Watcher of videos that are
over 40 minutes long wow I should be you
know fanned for making videos sorry
about that I would like to thank Welsh
fan Mark Henley Brandon Brian pin Yun
young and Cara bot for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and again sorry about
it yeah 40 going into 43 let's end it
now see you
soon